une petite coupe rapide je ne suis pas
le coiffeur je nettoie seulement et bien
c'est tout ce que je veux nettoyer
derrière et sur les côtés sans toucher
les pêcheurs
oui mais admet allez mon petit gars au
boulot comme vous voulez monsieur à
[Musique]
boudebouz
non
beaucoup
[Musique]
non
je
[Musique]
d'accord
non mais j'ai pas envie nelson ce n'est
qu'une coupe de cheveux il n'y a pas de
quoi avoir peur enfin excusez moi
monsieur lawrence e
je me demandais si je pouvais vous
toucher un mot sur la nourriture envoyé
un médecin la comptine tu es venu se
plaindre au non ce n'est pas une plainte
au quel dommage moi je suis ravi qu'on
vienne pour ce coup là c'est vrai oui oh
eh bien dans ce cas c'est très granuleux
aux grues bleus et puis alors le pain
que dire de plus je pense qu'il va
falloir revoir complètement le menu dont
je sais que nous avons un budget serré
mais on pourrait ajouter un peu de sauce
aux excès
attendez je vais ou non ça ne fait que
d'étaler pas de souci je sais comment
les détache de katcha attendait c'était
la moutarde ça au nom finalement c'est
pire encore quelqu'un sait ce qui marche
pour le ketchup les gars oublier le
médecin appelé un prêtre
écoute moi bien petit asticot je vous
écoute et si personne ne critique ma
bouffe c'est clair record personne
n'envoie des condiments sur mon tablier
entendez personne ne me tape sur la tête
avec une baguette à taper je vais revoir
le menu c'est vrai aujourd'hui ses
pattes et ours brun l'ambassade
qu'est ce qu'un succès c'est mon
sandwich à la marmelade marmelade
c'est ma tante lucie qui m'a appris la
recette tu veux dire que je suis fier ça
eh bien oui bouffe pas de là haut
qu'est ce que c'est as tu parles du
livre pop up
voilà qui est intéressant c'est vrai à
wil madame brosseau l'aube avait une
arrière grand mère qui a créé cette fête
et qui était d'une artiste brillante à
chaque fois qu'elle visitait une
nouvelle ville elle fabrique importe
pour s'en souvenir
oh et celui ci est sur londres au
monsieur grubert ces magnifiques temples
ici a toujours rêvé de venir à londres
et elle n'en a jamais eu l'occasion mais
ciel voyait ça ce serait comme si elle y
était enfin
[Musique]
opposés
au musée
[Musique]
omaha
viens avec moi tant pis ça avec plaisir
je veux te voir
alors qu'est-ce que tu en dises
d'extraordinaire
embarquement
quitter pour amorcer vie
sûr à la marche madame
bien élevé
quels jeunes pigeons bienvenus
[Musique]
au dim tonnes tu as fait le bonheur
d'une vieille osmont petit c'est parfait